you have a paper on nuclear fusion
uh magnetic control of tokamak plasma is
through deep reinforcement learning so
you uh
you're seeking to solve nuclear fusion
with deep rl uh so it's doing control of
high temperature plasmas can you explain
this work
and uh can ai eventually solve nuclear
fusion
it's been very fun last year or two and
very productive because we've been
taking off a lot of my uh dream projects
if you like of things that i've
collected over the years of of areas of
science that i would like to i think
could be very transformative if we
helped accelerate and uh really
interesting problems scientific
challenges in of themselves
this is energy so energy yes exactly so
energy and climate so we talked about
disease and biology as being one of the
biggest places i think ai can help with
i think energy and climate uh is another
one so maybe they would be my top two um
and fusion is one one area i think ai
can help with now fusion has many
challenges mostly physics material
science and engineering challenges as
well to build these massive fusion
reactors and contain the plasma and what
we try to do and whenever we go into a
new field
to apply our systems is we look for we
talk to domain experts we try and find
the best people in the world to
collaborate with um
in this case in fusion we we
collaborated with epfl in switzerland
the swiss technical institute who are
amazing they have a test reactor they
were willing to let us use which you
know i double checked with the team we
were gonna use carefully and safely um i
was impressed they managed to persuade
them to let us use it
and um and it's a it's an amazing test
reactor they have there and uh they try
all sorts of pretty crazy experiments on
it and um the the the what we tend to
look at is if we go into a new domain
like fusion what are all the bottleneck
problems uh like thinking from first
principles you know what are all the
boss net problems that are still
stopping fusion working today and then
we look at we you know we get a fusion
expert to tell us and then we look at
those bottlenecks and we look at the
ones which ones are amenable to our ai
methods today yes right and and and then
and would be interesting from a research
perspective from our point of view from
an ai point of view and that would
address one of their bottlenecks and in
this case plasma control was was perfect
so you know the plasma it's a million
degrees celsius something like that
hotter than the sun
and there's obviously no material that
can contain it so they have to be
containing these magnetic very powerful
superconducting magnetic fields um but
the problem is plasma is pretty unstable
as you imagine you're kind of holding a
mini sun mini star in a reactor so you
know you you kind of want to predict
ahead of time what the plasma's going to
do so you can move the magnetic field
within a few milliseconds you know to to
basically contain what it's going to do
next so it seems like a perfect problem
if you think of it for like a
reinforcement learning prediction
problem so uh you know your controller
you're gonna move the magnetic field and
until we came along you know they were
they were doing it with with traditional
operational uh research type of uh
controllers uh which are kind of
handcrafted and the problem is of course
they can't react in the moment to
something the plasma's doing that they
have to be hard-coded and again knowing
that that's normally our go-to solution
is we would like to learn that instead
and they also had a simulator of these
plasma so there were lots of criteria
that matched what we we like to to to
use
so can ai eventually solve nuclear
fusion well so we with this problem and
we published it in a nature paper last
year uh we held the fusion that we held
the plasma in specific shapes so
actually it's almost like carving the
plasma into different shapes and control
and hold it there for the record amount
of time so um so that's one of the
problems of fusion sort of um solved so
i have a controller that's able to no
matter the shape uh contain it continue
yeah contain it and hold it in structure
and there's different shapes that are
better for for the energy productions
called droplets and and and so on so um
so that was huge and now we're looking
we're talking to lots of fusion startups
to see what's the next problem we can
tackle
in the fusion area
you